foreign
now we're just going to sub in names I'm
excited Matt's coming I want to say hi
to him oh yeah what's up just tell him
to come in when he gets here you can
finish I think he's coming later I think
there's a gap
yeah you're looking this does not look
like a dude stacked who just I guess
just got married that makes sense yeah
yeah yeah you look beefy man the arms
are popping thank you looking good
thanks I mean this is like it's how many
days a week in the gym five oh damn and
what and do you cut out any types of
food are you like well this past week
I've been eating like but but Italy
Italy food is no process no
chemicals I feel like it's real food
yeah Italy I was good at Italy I did
really well at but generally speaking I
mean it's kind of just like chicken and
rice and yogurt and chicken rice is good
isn't it sounds great this is the best
I've ever eaten it's not great I mean
it's not like pizza doesn't that piss
you off when when The Rock shows his
cheat meal and it's like the healthiest
meal I've had all week it's just like a
cup of yogurt with one strawberry yeah
well it's like sushi was his I'm like
sushi it was healthy I thought that was
healthy it's fish I don't know there
might be a lot of I don't know if it's
healthy I don't think it's like I don't
know anything about sushi to tell you I
can't eat sushi though rice has no
gluten fun fact really so I'm not good
with the gluten I eat it but I'm not
great with it but I'm rice all day
I love rice but bread
and we just started out on a really boy
is my workhouse bringing this podcast to
a screeching hole no I was just kidding
that's true I know when you say glued
and I was like we better move this
studio to Los Angeles I guess I just
thought of sodium all right so I just
saw panicking Sam's eye I was like I
should probably hold on guys everybody
keto what do you think
Gotta Get Your Greens you're married I
am isn't that crazy whoa yeah what I got
a text from Rosebud like two days before
I was like I heard no Fanfare I know
first of all you for doing a Friday
afternoon wedding when all your friends
are comedians we had to we had to
because we did it at City Hall which by
the way is like getting married at Six
Flags and um
I mean they like you go in a line you
like rush you in there's like a
photographers running around trying to
get your pictures in front of this like
fake sort of like capital building
looking thing an old deranged man
dancing yeah everyone's ugly they have
funnel cake you know
and we're trying to act with seeds to
get catch more birds for more protein
they need more pigeons out there we're
dressed like a gay couple from like 19
like we own like a gay porn shop in
1976. we're dressed completely
ridiculous but you know there we are
yeah you guys look like the serial
killers in a David Lynch movie
that's what we were going for this is
crazy aren't we cute very cute I know we
look ridiculous yeah I was wearing like
Austin power but my friend Taylor
Warrior dressed us and he was like ah I
love these boots and I don't know how
you're gonna feel about them and I was
like are they Austin power boosts like
if they're too silly we don't have to do
it I was like no I'll do it I'll do it
go all in so there's nobody but you guys
um no we had like some people we had we
had like a small group of people coming
we had to get like a witness and stuff
and of course like we need like a
witness and someone to sign an affidavit
affidavit and I was like who's the most
professional person I know is that Liz
you're my witness I've got it and Liz
was so Liz who walked in she had
everything in a folder and they're like
we need your ID here's your IDs like we
need your uh certificate we have here
you know she's at best witness is
murder in weddings have similarities
like witness you only hear like a murder
or a wedding pronounce pronounced dead
pronounced husband and husband life
sentence life centers Catholics yeah
um you know it's funny when we got
married we get married by like I don't
know some some sort of Judge some some
lady from the Bronx and yeah you could
see her because she's just doing this
all day so you could see her
struggling like
do you take him with a husband and so
when we said our idea our ideas she goes
you may now kiss the husband and then
she literally goes folds her things and
goes have a nice weekend
a Vegas wedding in New York basically
yeah but Vegas at least if you're
married by Elvis there's some kind of
you know magic this was just like being
married at an H R Block yeah it's like a
DMV of marriage literally worse it was
like yeah like a Starbucks or something
like or Caribou Coffee who's drinking
Caribou Coffee
will you I mean look if you're in an
airport sometimes you have no choice no
it's not my first it's not my go-to
let's give you a scolding hot latte with
eight tenths of milk yeah that's all
milk gross but anyways the wedding
itself was great and then Liz had a
reception for us with the seller and
Johnny one of the waiters he made me
this giant wedding cake for us it was
unbelievable so I have a bunch of people
we have some gifts for you too you got
that right can I open them now open them
on air okay for you as well well people
get and we totally got this few it
wasn't our podcast producer who did it
when we went to town and we wrapped them
there was Us open up the card okay Mr
Mister I got a tattoo oh I think we're
high five that is a cool test is it I
got it in Rome it was pretty
uncomfortable okay so yeah here's to
your day your life and your love here's
to the two of you congratulations love
Samurai Mark Norman I wrote that there
you go all right I'll start with this
one first and people kept saying it like
Schultz was like do you have a registry
I was like I have no more space in my
apartment yeah do not send a New Yorker
any gift New Yorkers are the only people
who are annoyed by gifts yeah my mom
will get me books and I'm like what are
you trying to drown me I know I am so
happy you sent this to me I genuinely
I'm not making this up I literally was
like I need to go yeah
this is great this was laying around the
studio
no no I'm just kidding no I mean even if
it was it's great look I love how they
Circle the parts of your body where you
can shave it yeah like it's some sort of
CIA all right that's well hold that up
for the for the cameras yeah you got to
show your uncle's body there we go thank
you Hannah he's shaving trim oh my God
that's sweet all right do you shave your
pubes what are you doing I give it a
trim around the thighs because I get
that nasty uh off-grown thigh hair yeah
so I try to keep it all in this Infinity
do you know that I just bought one no I
have one and I also just did this is why
people get registered horrible
ninja please yeah I'll take it take it
you're so sorry I can't Mark's gonna
take Mateo's wedding gift best sweating
ever all right
but can you imagine if I had two ninja
bullets in my apartment we'll give it to
a homeless guy but I love the ninja I
mean I use it oh great and I feel like
you do a lot of protein shakes right yes
yeah yeah and it's good for other stuff
too all right now we're talking oh my
God this is great oh a bed sheet set
yeah you gotta get that jizz all off of
the old one take that home and throw
your husband's face right into those
dude that's Lacoste baby yeah you guys
really were thinking about gays shaving
our body nutrition and clean bed sheets
nothing better than this these are the
most important thing I mean you need
good bet also for how often we're on the
road you want to go home you want to
know I got home late at night from the
road like I can't I mean like probably
got in like midnight not brutal but late
collapse on the sheets nothing
better nothing better the best and I
wash my sheets once every Olympics
so your wife washes your sheets she's
better than me but she's no prize we get
along I'll tell you my wife she's all
right she's in the clan so she has to
watch them a lot but yeah oh I got you I
got you some prep hold on no I'm just
kidding he's trying to keep the game
like Mark you should keep that for
yourself you might need it more than I
will after my sheets yeah you can't
catch anything but yeah I got married
it's so crazy how do you crazy I feel
great I mean I do feel like this was
sudden this was I mean it was wildly
sudden yeah my ring looks like it's from
Lord of the Rings oh yeah we went for it
and then the woman the guy at David
Yurman where we got them from was so
nice he was gay walked in and he goes
and so he obviously helped us but then
we walked in to pick them up because
they were delivered there were dressed
in gym clothes and it was like out of
movies she just almost walked up she's
like
and can I help you oh geez it's like
whoa yeah New York someone lives in a
studio killing cockroaches all day on
her time off my god well she didn't I
mean you think just showing up like that
they would it's two magicians show up
but you know it's a lot more fun you
guys look like you're doing two at the
Borgata later this week oh yeah we look
like we own two exotic tigers and we
have a show in Vegas ah yes exactly what
else do we look like I mean we had to
roast ourselves I mean I just
um let's see we look like an ad in the
subway for prep yeah we go
or two really flamboyant lawyers like
celino and Barnes kind of thing call
1-800 flamboyant
you look like realtors that only show
suede Apartments oh yeah
all right good I mean we look like
lesbians hey a little bit don't worry a
little bit and we sort of act like
lesbians we fight like lesbians how do
lesbians Fighters are like yeah
I mean come on let's get them that ends
quick but we normally people like fight
fight but we're just sort of like I felt
a shift in your energy and I want to
talk about that like it's very that's
how you fight that's essentially yeah
it's pretty depressing I assumed gay
couple's just fenced you know when you
guys got mad at each other do you guys
are you both in therapy is that why you
fight like that I'm in therapy at he was
in therapy too he's he's still in
therapy people who fight in therapy are
excruciating Jonah Hill perfect example
oh those texts oh yeah well what the
hell but that doesn't well the fights
take the fights take way longer because
it's I feel like that adds another I
know that adds more time I will say we
have a problem because it Loops a lot
and that we have a hard time just sort
of like squashing and they're not fights
I mean they're just sort of like I feel
sad now you're like okay you just keep
feeling things it never ends let's get
to the point yes no it's hard but we're
doing we're getting better you know we
don't we really don't argue that much
how long into the relationship did and
who propose by the way who proposes in
the game I proposed uh which is shocking
because I bought them but um really yeah
well I mean we've flipped back and forth
but
um full Kaepernick like like uh men and
women like me can I tell you that when I
did it I was so embarrassed because it
was so heterosexual that I didn't even
know how like I was like you know what I
mean like there was a kind of at a I got
a nice uh hotel for us in Williamsburg
that like faced the whole city and you
know I feel like most of the proposals
in Williamsburg are ironic yeah I
brought like a parrot to do it for me
that's also like my shoulder pad I mean
all the proposals are like you want to
get married or like whatever I don't
care
the hotel wasn't as nice as I thought it
was what hotel so shade should I sure
yeah we sit at the William Valley oh
trash Heap but I thought it was gonna be
nice then I was like oh this is if like
an elevator was made into a giant hotel
like it's just first of all can I just
talk about what's with what's with the
barn doors the slight barn doors or the
bathrooms so now everyone just has to
hear me yes and then you gotta go
clock clock clock
like no give me a door and
there's no difference with the sound so
it's like whatever's happening in that
toilet right is being ha is happening
throughout the room so I'm like put your
headphones on like this what's the
school go back what's the Google Website
look good well that's what I'm saying
more for though for a five-star hotel I
want a four six okay well I had those
stains on the sheets oh I was mad
I don't know
Brown yellow red Brown oh what what is
brown that's only one thing that's brown
blackface either someone was eating
chocolate way late at night or just
someone took a huge out of the bed
look at this review one one out of five
we booked for one night here to
celebrate my husband's birthday however
it has been an unpleasant experience for
the following reasons one when we first
check in the room didn't have a mini
fridge which you need to put oh okay
this woman seems insufferable dogs food
I'm just saying I don't want to hear
someone's when they're in the
bathroom
um
what are you eating tonight
Mark is a cartoon character
I was just in Vermont and we were in a
hotel it was like expensive for a shitty
ass Hilton oh because that's all they
had available and uh I mean you know
you're staying in a and you
walk in and uh immediately it's late at
night we get in we're getting for the
gig the next day and some dude walks up
to me and my tour Majors kind of like
play defense because he thinks he
recognizes me yeah but he's just a drunk
who sees me holding a 12-pack of Seltzer
and the guy thinks it's beer so he's
trying to get a beer off me he goes is
that beer and I was like ah go away oh
weird so we go in no Wi-Fi they
ended up comping enough there was no
Wi-Fi in my room for some reason and and
everyone's they're like yeah Sam
no Wi-fi let me set it up the Wi-Fi
engineer comes up she can't figure it
out whoa and then as he's leaving he
goes I'm a big fan I'm coming tomorrow
I felt bad because I I couldn't be a
piece of because when we got there
we got drinks and they kept giving us
drinks so like we recognize you and we
love you we just want to say thank you
have all the drinks you want it's like
no I can't be a piece of and you're
not a big drinker so you're not even
thinking I had like one Margarita I'm
like you know so but the room itself was
just like it's I guess it's fine but
like I don't know like the New York
things I feel like big cities they
really skimp on the room size New York
definitely because there's just not
enough I mean there's really just not
enough space yeah but I mean none of
those lights work by the way I could not
figure out the lights and then they had
to bring the light guy up and then the
light guy couldn't figure out the lights
and I'm like I'm trying to plan like a
I'm trying to proposed the
illusion and all this money of the
getaway is gone once there's a strange
man in your room yeah it helps once
there's a dude trying to fix you're
like I may as well be at home with my
super I thought she was like okay my
house is I literally I'm like I can see
my house yeah I could have just done
this at home I know and it does look
great I mean I'm so
yeah the views are unbelievable but
those views I couldn't just go to
Williamsburg myself you know what I mean
I don't have yeah how is it how is it
stated you guys end up leaving some
stains of your own uh uh we I hope we
did good yeah yeah I will say I'm
embarrassed now my wedding night oh
it's my stain alarm
we were so drunk and so exhausted we
didn't bang and we banged the next
morning
we definitely had sex okay but yeah I
blew it is there a routine with gay guys
like which guy is it do you switch off
who comes first or what because you know
in a hetero relationship I kind of have
to make sure the woman comes first yeah
do that I have to
well then you know she's not coming once
I'm the game's over once I'm out true I
guess it's just like what
that was the last one
that rap
hey you're so ridiculous Mark that was
the first time I met you was 11 years
ago you were preparing for your first
Conan set and you're at the creek in the
cave and when you got off you farted oh
geez well see I never changed and it's
like the same who was that like you
never changed you never change you never
evolved nothing it's always never
changed my sheets you are you're like a
Simpsons character you were just sort of
this you've been the same he's kind of a
Rick from Rick and Morty a little bit
yeah I'm like the alien from American
Dad oh yeah I can see that
what uh so how you proposed on one knee
where was The Proposal uh at the hotel
right I had it all set up uh like a
marry me in like a you know like a nice
pretty thing that's great I know that
that moment was really nice like to have
that moment but then you know and you
met this guy through Instagram we met
through Instagram in February who who
damned who me I'm desperate he was doing
a video where he was like getting ready
you know those like almost soft softcore
porn videos of like guys and girls like
here's that I dressed in today and they
start in their underwear and then they
pull up their clothes and stuff like
that oh I love those a thirst trap
there's a total thirst trap so I was
like going through his Instagram God
damn this guy's ripped yeah he's hot hot
as Jesus Christ he is really you're not
so bad yourself Mateo yeah I look all
right I got I'm getting more hair
transplants in January so are you really
I really I thought it was a one and done
no I I want I went back for my year post
and uh he was really happy and so was I
and they were so nice and I was like you
know I was like honestly I want my hair
to wear it really short like I know
you're gonna fight me on this but can I
bring it in and bring in hair here it's
like absolutely oh okay and they're
gonna give me more of a beard I don't
have a beard whoa so just don't overdo
it as a friend hair okay okay these
plastic surgery ladies and they they
lose touch it's gonna look like Liza
Minnelli in three years yeah I'm still
excited
I'm going on tour and it's called it's
the desperate tour but you know what a
Madonna and you see her now like come on
she was good to like she was a couple
surgeries ago she was still pretty good
that's that's filler and like faceless
yeah and so I'm literally just getting
hair okay okay I just want some hair
Madonna looked good in 2008 she got
plastic surgery the very first time and
she looked great yeah let's go
back when she looked good yeah she looks
good there no not at the end not the end
type it type in Madonna plastic surgery
2008 see what we come up with I think
I'm such a that is the year okay
um that one yeah the bottom bottom one
with the uh oh whichever one oh my God
yeah she looks like a Mortal Kombat
villain even Jesus Christ she's zendar
or whatever except you never say get
over here yeah all right
boy she was sexy and now there's a thing
online called the Madonna challenge have
you seen this no what's that the lady
try to jack off to her it's really hard
here's my thing about Madonna I love
Madonna and Madonna wants if she wants
to look that way she has every right to
look however she wants to I don't know
what it's like to be an age you know all
those tropes right yeah but I will say
when they took pictures of her at the
Grammys and her immediate response was
that it's a bad camera lens it's this
it's that it's like what if you if
you're happy with the way you look then
say yeah I am happy with how I look
that's where all the bad cameras are the
award shows yeah maybe that's the best
like no one can afford a good camera
there
I know poor Madonna Madonna challenge is
where you try to keep up with her
dancing at a show and it's insanely
difficult I tried it last night I
couldn't do it like oh she's an
incredible dancer incredible but I mean
just the the stamina the endurance it
takes to do what she's doing I can't
imagine like a Beyonce show or something
can you imagine the cardio no totally
and being having and singing singing
yeah like Beyonce is singing incredibly
well and dancing and dressed in
like the most amazing outfits you can
imagine and I don't know what she's done
I mean she looks the same like she
hasn't changed no just she gets more
gorgeous every year yeah she
looks Brittany I mean what I mean what's
going on now with her you're a big
Britney person
um I was I actually was more of a
Christina fan growing up well because I
like singers but Christine has been
nothing but a disappointment for the
past 12 years so oh how so I don't know
she just seems kind of mean and doesn't
pick good music okay she's an incredibly
talented singer who has not chosen good
I I hate to say it but she needs like a
Svengoolie to sort of like hey here's
the music you should sing right but
maybe she doesn't want that career
anymore I don't know I mean she's not
fine I'm sure yeah Genie in a Bottle was
big yeah but Britney I don't know I was
I I was my my gayness my Divas were like
Mariah Whitney Patty Aretha like I
wanted the singers I wasn't so into like
the uh
yeah I mean I'm listening to like Aretha
Franklin from 1968.
together remember uh oh maybe this
wasn't the one we were at together was
it a roast where Aretha sang oh wow it
was uh you saw it was a Matt Lauer roast
oh years ago this is damn clearly years
ago
there's a lock on the door yeah but uh
nope I'm there and uh I'm in the back
and it was a fun roast I mean
she does a preemptive Aretha Franklin
does the national anthem before the road
she was like a big get and then Jeff
Frost comes out and goes wow usually
it's it's over when the fat lady sings
she got a big one of these yeah good for
her every time she flicked them off oh
yeah oh good for her well I Love Aretha
Franklin is the queen of shade oh really
oh my God you don't the interviews they
ask her like they're like this guy's
like I just want to ask you about
certain singers do you mind and we just
get your impression then she's like yes
absolutely like you know Mariah Carey a
singer a good songwriter like Whitney
Whitney was a talent a real talent she
goes Alicia Keys good songwriter Taylor
Swift
gorgeous gowns oh gorgeous gorgeous
gowns beautiful gowns wow gorgeous gowns
and then like Nicki Minaj she goes I'm
just gonna skip wow I've never seen uh
people lose their in my lifetime
the way I've seen Taylor yeah yeah I I
I'm so what am I missing I don't get it
like I think Taylor Swift's great super
talented great songwriter but when you
watch Whitney Houston from the 80s I
mean you forget what the standard is yes
you forget what like oh yeah we didn't
need uh dancers we didn't need fireworks
we didn't need this literally just a
woman with a microphone and a piano what
about Tina Turner unbelievable but
different kind Tina Turner was a
phenomenal singer different type of
singer yeah phenomenal singer phenomenal
dancer phenomenal Entertainer and had
real Charisma I mean she really could
Captivate an audience and you know she
was like the Madonna in Europe really oh
yeah she I mean she in America she was
everyone knows her and loves herself but
in Europe she was I mean because she's
number one when she died I think she was
living out she was living in Switzerland
yeah yeah not Europe but it's close yeah
yeah it's Europe I've been drinking yeah
north of Italy
um curveball on voices okay you're not
gonna like it
Sinead Sinead O'Connor yes I mean as a
singer I don't I don't think technically
she was a great singer but she was
probably a singer that was meant more
for like meaning and interpretation ah
okay so I don't think it was she wasn't
like Barbra Streisand like here I am
have you seen Streisand live oh yeah I'm
obsessed I grew up listening to
Streisand my aunt said and I are
completely obsessed and then when she
was she was years ago like five years
ago she was doing three concerts she
just for whatever reason she was doing
the United Center in Chicago Madison
Square Garden New York and then whatever
the Hell in L.A and she sells out like
that you know yeah so my Anthony I
immediately bought tickets she came out
she's like 76 at the time she came out
she started singing We started bawling
wow and she could still sing and then
Ariana Grande came out to do a duet with
her wow and Barbara's out singing Ariana
and then the bomb hit and then we were
in Manchester
what about some dudes I mean all I know
is Stevie Wonder is the greatest male
singer Stevie Wonder Luther
okay okay and I like his Christmas song
yeah yeah how about I'm thinking of
other dudes Pavarotti though pull up a
Pavarotti Pavarotti Bocelli
Andre Bocelli is an amazing I like
Bocelli he's my guy yeah more more The
Three Tenors yeah yeah oh my God The
Three Tenors those concerts I like the
blind thing I like these blind his son
is his son is a good looking he's got
all the it looks like Bocelli's son has
got all the looks and oh his kids are
really good looking oh really yeah yeah
yeah and he's got the talent and he gets
to see that's like up that's true
his dad was more I would say
contemporary for men there's no other
one he gets him like a domestic dispute
he still can raise his voice oh yeah and
I wonder right he's had a lot
trust me he's had so many Mistresses and
kids oh yeah
yeah did you watch his doc yeah that's
what I learned about it great Ducks
saying he could not stop cheating and
you're like this guy looks like Dom
DeLuise but if you got the talent no if
you got skills you're in yeah for
straight people yes yes your gay dudes
are like up hey guys they see me
on stage well I used to make this joke
before I was known but like it was hard
doing gay shows when I first started
doing stand-up because you know if gays
don't know who you are they want to see
women that's how we associate comedy a
lot of times or drag queens right so I
would get on stage and try these jokes
that I was doing at the creek in the
cave and you could just almost feel them
being like where's Kathy Griffin you
know I hear this at brunch who cares
like because the gays are all funny so
they're all like we don't what the
is this guy offer so the gay shows were
really really hard in the beginning
really hard yeah a gay silence is loud
okay
shows like gay audiences are very uh
tough audiences because what they do is
they don't respond if you're not funny
they just turn and talk to each other oh
that hurts worse than that it's brutal
it's brutal I did a show I never enjoyed
performing in Vermont I gotta say really
why I did I did a show that I well first
off where are we performing Higher
Ground uh it's a it's like a Aretha
Franklin song Oh no higher love I'm
thinking I'm sorry go ahead there was no
love that night I'll tell you no it was
uh I'm doing uh you know Vermont and
it's weird I have a thing where like
first off I I have a weird head I got
assaulted there a guy smashed a pint
glass over my head in Vermont yeah I
know this peaceful ski chalet palette
they're no they're Ben and Jerry
by the way that city is oh yeah but it's
it's yin and yang yeah yeah you get the
kind of like the hippie dippies but then
you get the dudes who are like the Bros
who are like the words I wish they were
in Boston I mean it's weird to be
liberal but also like gun people though
that's what they are oh that's true
Dorsey you don't see that combination
like anywhere there's no like especially
not Manhattan well there's no like well
there's no like conservative Market
that's like pro-abortion it's just a
weird yeah it's a weird combo you're
right so we uh you know uh
we're doing the show by the way the
people there are like they're
losing it we I'm with Brian my tour
manager we're just taking a walk we're
gonna go play basketball at the Y as
we're walking by there's a there's a
woman on drugs and she just turns to us
and he goes both of you I hope you
suck dicks forever
like it's like all you can do is laugh
yeah of course that's awesome but the
show is no the show is a mess
it's like one of those things where
they're just so they're on drugs they're
just not laughing or showing drugs and
it seems like they're having a great
time but I'm hating it this guy won't
stop heckling me then he tries
to come backstage and they let him
backstage what are you doing they're
like oh he works for the venue and I'm
like oh the guy who ruined my show oh my
God oh my God he didn't ruin it but he
was annoying us now no he ruined anyone
who's I hecklers I have zero times they
don't they don't know when to
I have one joke that's a long story and
he just completely ruins cut it off and
then you have to rebuild the momentum
you know that drives me crazy I had a
you guys have a safe word in the
audience you know like buy that guy a
drink means throw him out no I say to
them I say this person needs to go oh
but there you go I will say I've been
very very very lucky knock on wood that
I I really have quite great well-behaved
audiences really yeah I I do not usually
that's the case for me the other show
this weekend were great we did
Providence Northampton and uh
Albany is beautiful the egg is beautiful
oh the egg's awesome I think it's
because I have a bunch of gays and we
all perform so we know what it's you
know what I mean yeah they have an idea
of like this works the other way though
sometimes the people that are also like
I do this are the worst audience
but I will say I I don't there's they
ask me what's your code where I said
there's no code word I will say out
front this person has to leave yeah and
I give zero time I have zero tolerance
for hecklers zero people think I mean
and I'm like I don't care if I bomb if
someone's heckling the first 15 minutes
I get them out and if I bomb for the
next 45 minutes I go to bed happy that
night I don't care good for you
because my worry is I'll I'll derail the
show I'll lose momentum and I'll it
up I don't care now you've heard that
story I forgot who it is it might have
been like orney Adams or someone I do a
great morning Adam's impression well you
could do this after yeah so he uh
apparently I think it was hilarities or
something he has a code word his code
we'll just get this guy a cola and they
just forgot so that's what I was getting
at that happened to me he's gonna get
this guy a cola will someone get him a
Cola yeah because he doesn't
want to be the bad guy when they get
tossed up this happened to me I was at
the Taft theater in Cincinnati it was a
couple in the front from Kentucky going
we love you but you everything I'd say
they're like going into the setups I'd
be like so I got a ninja and they're
like whoa ninja you know they're just so
up and I my code word is tased
this because it's just kind
of funny you know so I go tase this
and you know everybody
laughs nothing happens and I go can
someone tased this no one
does anything and then like they're
gesturing me on the side of the stage
and I looked through the curtain and the
guy's going he's like hitting a taser oh
my God you want to do this and I was
like no no don't actually taze them so
they just stayed the whole show damn so
then after like what happened I'm like
[Music]
I think I hate more than heckling I'd
rather someone purposely Heckle me than
someone who thinks they're supporting me
talking at me because we can do
something with that yeah right we can we
can kind of yes and the the Heckler
that's right but if it's someone who's
like just like cheering you on you're
like now you're just with the
flow yeah and I say there was I was in
Houston doing a couple of uh shows
getting my hour together for this tour
The Improv and
um there were issues uh but I
um the audiences were fantastic but one
show there was a a couple in the front
they were really talkative and at one
point I was just like you guys I can
hear every word you're saying and it's
incredibly distracting so if you want
this show to go well can you just stop
and then they stop oh okay you know so
sometimes sometimes just be honest like
I know sometimes it's not about the joke
you just say like hey I want to let you
know you know what I say a lot if
someone like at the seller if someone
heckles and stuff I'm like everyone this
person here this is called a narcissist
this person that's catty as I like
it I go in I never yell I never say
you you don't want to make it
uncomfortable that way you can't bite
too quickly because I've seen I was at
the comic strip once and I saw a
comedian who's got a bit of a temper I
love the way he handled this he just no
one else can see what's going on except
him so he just turns him and goes
you get AIDS and goes right back
into his act I was like you can't fight
that quickly dude wow I've seen some
Comics some Pro Comics like you know oh
yeah then go in and I was talking to
Sarah talamas years ago we were at the
stand years ago the old stand and she
goes someone was we were telling me Oh
they got into a fight with a Heckler and
the terror goes you know
I think almost 100 of the time I'm on
the comic side and I was like yeah me
too yeah usually although one time I did
see one where comic snapped at a guy at
stand up New York and it was it was
pretty it escalated really quickly and a
guy in the front row an old guy goes
tell a joke the comedian puts
the mic down and does this
so I'm kind of like what the is
like a fight about to go down this
comedian like he will kick this guy's
ass so I turn to the host I'm like yeah
you should probably do something the
host takes out a camera phone and starts
recording it that was his idea of do
something I'm like take him off
stage or dude you know yeah yeah so what
happened hey the guy who got off stage
and he left why you just can't though no
fight the trick is you can't like scream
and yell you can't actually fight
because you are trying to like keep the
temperature in the room you just have to
be I my Approach is always like I'm just
super direct and honest I'll say like
I'm just letting everybody know like
it's really difficult on stage when I I
have a rhythm of how I speak and if
someone keeps talking to me if that
Rhythm gets ruined I can't get myself
and then the joke is ruined then there's
you know a thousand people here and then
the shows ruined for you guys like that
I'm just explaining to what's going on
and then people kind of they you have to
get them on your side because otherwise
we just look like crazy people like shut
the exactly and the person in the
balcony is like what yes Diva but we
ever have the thing where you're like
hey could you guys stop talking they're
like oh you and you're like wait
why are you mad at me you're the one
talking at a show I hate that and you
don't want to come off like it like a
day yeah yeah I had to think we're
taking the car service back yesterday
from Albany it's me I just love our
lives by the way I love car service my
true energy one with Gary veter who
opens James who films and uh and uh
Brian the tour manager Brian is
he's so direct that it's uncomfortable
yeah like uh the driver won't shut the
up he like keeps telling us bad
jokes and they don't have endings their
jokes where they're just like and we're
like going over the set and we're
talking about stuff we're talking about
Gary's special we're talking about like
you know we're working on a show
together and then he just keeps cutting
off he's like I got another one for you
we're like oh boy and there's no ending
so we're just sitting there pausing like
waiting on a punchline and then he takes
a phone call it's like a loud phone call
yeah it's like an expensive car service
so I kind of give my 200 mine a look
like this and he and he gives me like I
got this I'm like I don't know what I
got this he goes he turns to the guy
goes we'd like a quiet car for the rest
of the turn and I'm like what the
dude this guy's gonna drive us off the
road yeah I love him you crushed this
guy I love him I loved it too but I was
like God damn I mean I couldn't do it
couldn't do that Schumer used to do that
kind of stuff and I was like I wanted to
like hide my own that was so
uncomfortable I saw Amy do that before
this is pretty cool she's a pro I just I
don't have that uh that spine
it just depends on the situation I think
for me you know but I will say 99 of the
time like you know my eyelashes are
great totally I I'm having issues though
with the sound at theaters where I touch
the mic and no matter where I touch it
it's like
interesting and it happened at one
theater and I stood on the stage I go
hey this mic is making this noise and
then the sound guy goes well what do you
want me to do no and I go I don't know
this might surprise you but I'm not the
sound guy yeah and he goes well that's
just the way our mic sound I said let me
get this straight you have a 3 000 seat
theater here and this is the first time
you've ever heard a problem with the
microphone goes well maybe I'll get some
duct tape and put it around and I go you
can do whatever you want I was like but
we just need to fix the problem and
they're holding the room right so and
the whole staff is there like all the
ushers and everybody's in there and I'm
on stage going back with the sound guy
and he's making zero effort to fix it
and then when he goes you're just gonna
have to deal with it whoa I promise you
I am not leaving this stage until you do
your job and then my tour manager calls
her sound guy and she goes he said
change the channel so they change the
channel problem fix wow that guy should
be fired I don't even get me stuff that
there was a certain that's the job right
there was a certain theater very big
theater very big moment for me and uh
the two things happen one my host walks
on stage as he's walking on stage
they're not playing the music the second
he grabs the mic it says hello they
start playing the music that's happened
to me before I turned to the sound guy
and I say hey you need to play the music
the second he walks out and I'm not like
Hassan Minaj like I don't have like a
giant screen behind me and Views and
things that are you know like really you
gotta get it right it's like just play
the music so then Emma's opening for me
and in the middle of Emma's set they
start blasting my closer music
Annie Lennox walking on broken glass
so in the middle of Emma said it's like
walking up walking on broken glass I my
head whipped to the stage manager this
is the same guy yes and I said what the
are you doing and he was like sorry
his hand slipped his hand slipped I that
happens yeah I was on me too the whole
time in a rage like I did it but the
back of my head when I left I saw the
sound guy talking to my tour manager and
he goes Mateo really sorry about that
hiccup I said you should be and tell
your sound guy I'm pissed and I
left good I was mad it happened to Gary
but the song is I have him come out too
is I'm a by Meredith Brooks I like
what happened to him yeah
but at least you can use that it's a
funny song it's a funny tune it's a
funny song for Gary to walk out too yeah
do we just sound does your audience like
we talk this inside baseball sure yeah
that's a funny story oh play the clip I
sent you play the I send uh the I've
never seen this and I don't know you
guys have probably seen it but I saw for
the first time this I've never seen it
and we can't stop wait I have a real
scene from Intervention I know this okay
she's pulling this out pull it out okay
that's fine we'll go back into other
stuff
no he's he told the story
no I don't know what this is but this is
unhinged trying to eat well is
exhausting but when you change your
atmosphere you can also change your
habits with factor it's easier to heat
up a delicious healthy meal than it is
to hit a drive-through factors America's
number one ready to eat meal kit that
delivers dietitian approved meals right
to your door they're fresh never frozen
meals already in just two minutes way
faster than takeout I we got a lot of
these they were really good right so
good the smoothies are good they taste
good they're easy to make I mean it's
it's perfect for a just a dumb non-cook
guy and if you're on the go the
smoothies are great the the heat up it's
ready immediately it's so quick and it's
actually really good tasting and
nutritious to factor meals.com
drunk50 and use code drunk 50 to get 50
off that's drunk 5-0 at factormeals.com
drunk50 to get 50 off oh yeah
that was easy
hey hey folks looking for something to
do tonight well check out game time it's
the fast and easy way to buy tickets for
all the sports music comedy and theater
near you with Flash Deals and last
minute tickets
uh you can go to amazing events without
planning months in advance they even
have their game time guarantee so you
know you're getting the best price if
you find tickets in the same section and
row Elsewhere for Less game time will
credit you 110 of the difference wow
what a steal we know these places can
kill you with the charges the fees the
the crap the sub this and extra that
it's too much go out of town and see
what game time has offered has to offer
it's an amazing way to explore your city
at prices that won't break the bank
maybe we'll even see it one of our shows
huh get a ticket snag those tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account use code drunk for 20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem your code drunk
for 25 20 bucks off sorry download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price yeah guaranteed use promo code
drunk twenty dollars off this is from
Intervention somewhere
somewhere down
there's a real Pavarotti this guy great
voice
I still love you
look at this
what the
this is being Bobby Brown
it just sucks to have a bad cry yeah
here's the thing I've that show bothered
me because I just felt like they were
completely taking advantage of people
clearly of course of course like that
woman who was addicted to to like this
Huffer or whatever and she was like I
think I'm walking on
I was like okay
that's what Allison has to be associated
with that well she signed the release
you know that's how they get you do you
think that guy knows he has an awful cry
until he's not I think when you're on
Intervention that's the least of your
worries like this man is clearly doing
so much crystal meth that he's now on a
e or whatever Channel it used to
be on with his family being like I love
you with lights and sound like they had
to get miked for that like it's bad like
I wish a woman I broke up with had that
cry so I would have no second thoughts
because if you're just like I think we
should see other people
I might be like oh thank God this is the
right choice yeah that's great you know
those guys on the sound was like go with
the headphones like Jesus Christ
that totally came out of nowhere can we
watch more clips and make fun of them I
don't know yeah we're sure I just did a
whole uh my friend Gabby Bell's got a
really fun YouTube channel and we
watched remember the Magic Bullet the
infomercial yes we sat and watched the
whole thing in Reddit for Filth and
there's nothing better than infomercials
oh it's so funny but don't do that one
that one's that one's super current is
there any other show yeah these are
who's this these are really current and
this is not coming out for a minute
is that a joke
uh diva
uh what is I hope it's guilt too much
yeah he swallowed a pube women
okay so you're dating or you're engaged
or you're newly married or you're single
okay and you don't want to end up with a
corn addict you don't want to end up
marrying someone if you are against the
relationship so they're saying corn
because porn gets flagged by Tick Tock
oh I didn't know that because she's this
woman I haven't seen this but I've heard
about this
um yeah she's like a this woman
is the woman who was really mad about
Oppenheimer right can you get the other
one because Florence Pugh is naked in it
I haven't seen the clips but I've heard
about this guy pull up the other monster
will is she like super Christian yeah oh
by the way that's what's bothering you
about Oppenheimer not the um the
gym 200 000 Japanese people got murdered
thanks man what did you say you were
like oh geez tell it to Joe list
I posted a clip of me and will
around with it uh
okay any advice for my husband and I
wanting to watch Oppenheimer but being
fully afraid of the Florence he's scene
everyone's talking about there's two
sure have you guys seen Oppenheimer no
no I really wanted not yet I think it's
really good I'm dying to see it my
friend Nick he's so he's such an idiot
when it comes to history he was watching
oppenheim he goes why the hell do they
keep talking about the Nazis isn't this
Japan like you're an idiot that's
amazing okay
search I researched everything before we
watch do you but especially this movie
obviously I heard about it yes we wanted
to see it it has an amazing rating
um we prepared ourselves I didn't know
when the scene was going to happen and I
also didn't understand how the scene was
happening I thought it was just several
minutes straight of but it wasn't it was
actually broken up into like wow
there were also two nukes you dumb
it was like very you know back and forth
so it was really difficult to avoid it
but obviously my husband and I talk
about everything if we go we don't talk
about everything and you always wonder
who likes John Chris um
I like John he's a nice guy
you're talking about being triggered by
nudity during a war film yes yes with
murder a lot of murder knowing that like
how many millions of people in Hiroshima
are going to die and she's worried about
a dick or tits tits It's
crazy I thought the tits were would be
like a relief on the screen
so essentially
um what we did was
when the scene came up when things were
happening he literally closed his eyes
and laid his head on my shoulder
if this is my choice your husband's gay
yeah I don't know her husband but I know
he's gay literally I will tell you what
right now took nothing away from the
story him not looking at the screen
during
they must not have sex by the way this
is what my mom did to me when we saw he
got game in the theater she put her
hands over my eyes so I couldn't see the
titties really yeah and she did it to me
during that game is that the one where
he dresses up and drag to play
basketball that's Juana man you got
games like a good movie that's spikeless
very good is it okay yeah it's a good
flick but she did to me doing grifters
too uh Annette benning's perfect
young titties oh wait pull them up and
that Benning was a too much dime
piece oh yeah I don't remember ever
seeing her Young she I think she was hot
older I literally only she's hot in
American Beauty very hot in that with
the legs up getting plowed by Peter
Gallagher
I don't know if I'm with you on this one
dude she pulled Prime Warren Beatty are
you out of your mind yeah
he's a handsome guy do you know how much
Warren Beatty okay I like that one
all right don't go to the old bag what
are we doing here Peter you'd still hit
it dude I'm sure I would I saw in a
plane once with Warren Beatty man he was
handsome oh my God damn it donated
Warren baby oh yeah she pulled Prime he
was Bugsy like I think he was also
probably Odin on punani who do you think
is the hottest woman and man of all time
well wow
beauty is subjective if you had to pick
myself hottest man and hottest woman
Paul Newman's in the conversation yeah
look at Paul Newman yes young Paul
Newman's hottest oh yeah that's a
good dude pull
those eyes come on dude it's a
different era but yeah different area
yeah I guess young Marlon Brando for me
is he is a handsome Hunker she's having
young Marlon Brando yeah
that's a man right and a lot of like
Leading Men back there weren't
necessarily hot they were just cool like
buggy right but he's a weird looking
dude he is yeah yeah I do think Halle
Berry is the most beautiful person to
ever live she's up there I just don't
think there's I was watching X-Men young
Angelina Jolie yeah that's on my top
that's top five for me yeah she's
interesting looking yeah yeah she's
beautiful but never like I don't know
she's never quite dude pull up some
prime Angelina oh he can't beat I go
Ange over over bahali
Halle Berry's hot as oh my God
super stunning actually young
Sophia Loren oh that's in there I would
say young Sofia learning dude she's
gorgeous gorgeous are you kidding a
little too young before the nose job
that is a natural beauty that's insane
that's natural and she was nude
her kids look literally A Perfect Blend
between yeah and her can't go wrong
there I'm Eugene stunning well that's as
good as these three jeans I got from
doer thank you guys type in young Sophia
Loren yeah there you go
all right all right now how do we get on
this oh that Christian girl how did you
find her Sam I just it was like going a
few people said it to me yesterday it's
just like all over the internet I didn't
even watch it though because I want to
save it for this Carrie Grant's a
handsome dude too by the way yeah but I
think Mateo's issue back then is Mateo's
a big body guy and those dudes back then
had bodies no not so much about the
body guy even though I just married
Arnold Schwarzenegger but um hey that's
such a great picture yeah Manfield who
Mansfield was a dime piece so is
Mariska Hargitay though her daughter
early SVG never say her name she's
gorgeous beautiful God yeah Mansfield
good name for a gay bar hold on now
uh go go to Cary Grant as uh he's a hand
do you know Cary Grant he's a he's like
the George Clooney of uh of the 40s
is this a hot guy
yeah uh I mean it's a different era
again but look at the pool very cute
face yeah he's handsome okay he was a
handsome lady and he could do comedy or
drama man yeah Hitchcock notorious right
uh To Catch a Thief yes all those old
flips is that a gay photo of them oh
maybe he dabbled oh did he yeah oh good
for him he got a lot hotter
great oh dude you know what that movie
uh Arsenic and Old Lace that's like a
Michelle wolf favorite she's a it's like
an old comedy he did it's funniest
really slapstick weird I know it's a
little hacky but I do think uh that
emirata is very attractive I like a
different look I like a exotic kind of
nothing though she looks a lot like and
this is not taken away but a little bit
like the alien in Mars Attacks I'm okay
with that walks like a little bit that
was a cute alien look I'm not saying by
the way no one's funnier than Martin
Short I love Martin I've been watching
only murders in the building and he is
so
the best deaths with his Jimmy Cliff
it's so funny I can't get enough of it
it's ahead of its tie it's like pre Two
Ferns and all that it's gold you're
right holy and he was so mean to
those celebrities and they they took it
it's very too ferns AV shits on Seinfeld
all day and Seinfeld's on the floor
which is time to let him have it too
yeah that's true my favorite dude is
interviewing Eddie Edie Falco and he's
like what are you Italians try not to
kill people why do Italians try not to
kill people he has Mel Brooks he goes
what's your big beef with the Nazis
that's amazing wow that's amazing
Mel Brooks man that aliens not
Mel Brooks is we used to watch Mel
Brooks movies all the time
but a Young Frankenstein is my favorite
yeah good dollar rats yeah it's so good
I used to imitate Madeline Khan the
tired sick and tired of love I had no
idea what it was about but I just was
drawn to her she's amazing you know she
was an unbelievable opera singer what go
to madelinecon glitter and gay it's a
song and uh you will and just skip
halfway through you will not she was hot
too oh my God she's top top top top
there yeah yeah click on that one and
just skip like three quarters of the way
through
oh she was an unbelievable really oh yes
she was fully trained like the real deal
and you would never know because in that
movie she was tired
right was her like Will Ferrell I think
you could be funnier when you train
Sirius I agree he was like a
Shakespearean actor like a Leslie
Nielsen yes well this is she made this
song comedy too now we're talking we're
talking hot do we take in longevity does
that play a role we talking Peak are we
talking like Jane Fonda's got longevity
I feel like she's still hot oh Jane
Fonda looks great Sharon Stone looks
great she does pull her up Sharon Stone
today looks absolutely great
um I think Sofia Vergara will look the
same till she dies you're not so
funny though think about how deprived
everyone was like the basic Botox filler
and no no I'm talking about like the
scene in Basic Instincts where she does
this and and she shows her Beaver for
like literally three seconds and
everyone's like oh my God that's the
hottest scene and now now the internet I
mean that's like that should be PG
that's like this should be in the kids
film it's like an 18 year old's
Instagram post yeah it's not even like a
thing anymore yeah I mean she looks
great yeah she looks great hanging in
there the JLo looks great oh JLo
that's another one she will never age
you know Mariah is cuckoo bananas as she
is Mariah looks good yeah her right it
doesn't change those roller
skates would short shorts and fantasy if
you can pull that foot I've jerked off
to that poster I did a Mexican TV show
once called noches complatanito have
either one of you done it before no I
don't remember that okay well it's
embarrassing but um they dressed me up
like Mariah in fantasy and I was
rollerblading around in a wig and they
all just and they had they were playing
fantasy I'm like there's no way they got
the rights to this music that's the one
no that's from glitter type in Mariah
Carey Fantasy music video okay
sorry
Mariah is hot hot big cans too big lips
lips definitely help lips are good
both of them ah I miss young Mariah
Carey Mark who else is in the combo for
you for women I do like uh what's her
face Salma Hayek gorgeous and I like
Penelope Cruz gorgeous
um Ethan Ethan Sims Paris and I went
just saw this Italian movie with her in
it and she speaks Italian the whole film
how does she how many languages can she
act in I should probably I mean she was
a Spanish woman living in Italy so every
once in a while she would say something
Spanish but like I'm fluent in Italian
and she was a plus wow that's impressive
and smoking hot yeah she was
beautiful she's so good in Vicky
Christina Barcelona oh is she hot in
that that was supposed to be in that
role I auditioned and that I used to
joke with uh that lies because I do
believe Liza Minnelli thinks that she
could audition for any role yeah yeah
and I would do this on fortnite with my
friends all the time he's like I was
auditioning for Tomb Raider and it was
down to me and Angelina Jolie and I said
Angelina whichever one of us gets it
it's meant to be
um Natalie Portman I know it's a hat
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous I saw on
Broadway as Anne Frank oh I'm sorry hi
she playing Anne Frank she's a Jew
only for her but you I just can't
imagine you going to watch the Diary of
Anne Frank how old were you I was his
kid my parents died okay yeah I was it
wasn't like let's do this that's
good I do love it about you that you're
just like such a New Yorker that you
were seeing Broadway shows when you were
a kid that's why we remember when we
were up there with you and you didn't
think I'd know that much about Broadway
I loved it that was such a great clip we
should we're doing it in Chicago baby oh
we should do it at least I mean I know
you do whatever you do at your show but
at my show we're definitely doing it uh
we're doing back to back in Chicago I
heard Chicago Theater both of you in
Chicago September 29th September 30th
that's incredible so you guys will stay
an extra day or shy Town kids uh ride
again yeah I'm gonna sign the wall right
under Liza Minnelli oh that's great I'm
open for Aziz there and open for Schultz
there and so now that I'm performing
there I'm like okay I know that lies
this year yeah you do and I'm gonna sign
right under Mateo Lane Hometown boy
makes good uh yeah we were open for zizu
together I remember that oh my God my
family doesn't know you're coming
they're gonna die oh
but the big ones you kind of want to
chill yeah also it's a great Chicago is
one of the best cities yeah the best did
my special there just don't get hammered
the night before which is so hard
because you want to be fresh for the
yeah drinking City it really is a
drinking
yes I know it's disgusting it is
disgusting I can't believe you know what
that is of course they've made you try
it for years well deep dish pizza for
the first time I loved it really
fresh people hate that people hate on it
though because I always say I loved it
and people were like you uh pet
quads it turns out no one likes deep
dish pizza except Chicagoans and we're
fine with it I'm a thin crust guy for
sure that was like that was a terrible
idea I'll tell you man certain it'll put
you out we made the mistake we eat way
too much of my tour we because I have
Gary opening so we every meal is family
style a huge it's comical we ended the
show and you know we wanted to leave
right after Albany so we got a huge meal
before Middle Eastern food we've been
eating this like hummus gassy stuff
all day I'm dying veterans dying we're
in pain I was like we're never eaten
before the show like that again but we
had to leave so I get off stage I don't
care for gassy people
I think I'm gonna die doing this set
yeah I'm down in peppermint pills Shadow
uh Rick Glassman again I was performing
somewhere there was Pepto-Bismol I go oh
you guys that was Samurai
so I get uh I get off stage I'm dead I'm
like hurting and I collapsed I let out
the biggest fart right as I do it the
promoter comes in and I was just like oh
boy and then he goes uh he goes uh it
was great working with you I did the
show for you in Wilkes-Barre I was like
oh yeah I remember you and he goes oh I
wasn't there in person like well this
has been a great interaction I really
killed this one yeah you just want him
out so you can fart yeah so I can
release this tension you son of a
I'm such a the opposite on the road I'm
like I have chicken and rice and
vegetables like after I do sound check
and everything and then I don't eat
anything and then I go on stage when I'm
done I usually get a hotel 24-hour room
service so I can get like chicken oh wow
I gotta get that protein I know we eat
way too much on my tour it's not it's it
and then Gary blames me I'm like you're
the one who picks these
restaurants out let me ask you guys a
theater question we're all doing some
theaters now yeah
does yours come with a runner
everything I go to they're like this is
Bob your honor this is Sheila your
runner go get your yeah some do
some dumb I've had like you're paying
for that by the way you are I cut it out
because I've never used them so I'm like
I'll just get overreach once or
something we got coffee at the vet every
venue has coffee yeah coffee machine my
rider what's on your Rider like in The
Green Room what do you want let's hear
it let's do our Riders immunity shots
like the you know because you get
someone scratching your throat in a
different celebrities look at those
Gingy shots what do you like ginger
lemon uh that's clever I like those I
get I get Bodega cat whiskey obviously I
get vermouth the maraschino cherries the
bitters I want to make a Manhattan uh we
have uh I get a couple bottles of
natural wine just so like when we get
wine drunk after the shows I like having
I'm like having some wine you drink on
the road after the show of like one yeah
how do you guys we're strong you guys
look great don't seem disheveled how I
we play basketball every day Gary and
James will like do weights Brian and I
we play pickup ball and then you know we
do some light I'll do like pull-ups or
some just to like feel something
but yeah I don't uh plus they're sober
so that kind of helps yeah oh the feeder
had a couple drinks with me the other
day I'm breaking his ass because I'll
get Gary by lying about a bottle being
like old I'll be like this is like a 500
bottle of wine and be like and then
I'll try to be like 30 bucks
it's eight dollars mine's like peanut
butter and bread yeah and a bowl a thing
of fruit and like coffee water and
sugar-free Red Bull Michelle wolf gave
me that tip because you know when you're
doing like a club or something or like
back-to-back shows and you're exhausted
for that next show I because I was like
who tours more than Michelle yeah so I
said what the we do you do she's in
Europe what do you mean I know she's
touring now but this is years ago I
remember I was doing like a weekend at I
think Wise Guys and you know she was
doing like her 15th show at Comedy Works
or something I said how do you have the
energy to do it she goes sugar-free red
bag
I was like okay so I put over coffee is
sugar-free breakfast could get you a
jolt I just take three sips three or
four sips before my second show we we
were sponsored by Monster Energy on my
last tour and it was like God so I had
to have my cancer
it took so much energy not to on it
every night I mean I would and then we
just clip I would be like this is good
and they'd be like that'd be the one
yeah what if the Container Store wrote
back
I'm trying to let them know that they're
awful he's fighting with The Container
Store right now I do like The Container
Store the worst bit worst business use
other people trying to get a reaction oh
really well because I take it back
the containers through it yeah I spent
all this I think we got we
ordered stuff for them today actually
well do you know they have the alpha
shelving right so I order all this it
takes that takes forever it's super
expensive and then you're like okay come
deliver it on this day will they miss
the delivery day then they miss the next
delivery day then they're like well we
then they they're coming and they go is
it a walk-up we're like yeah well you
didn't tell us so we have to choose
another day like it's Manhattan then
they finally come they bring it right
and then they're supposed to install it
today so I get everything out of my
closets and I've got these giant pets
you can't walk in my apartment yeah and
it's a New York apartment you I can't
move and they say you know we're
coming between 11 and 5. so we're I'm
just sitting at home all day because I
cut out my day I'm like I have to wait
for this guy it's like the cable guy
right and then I finally called them and
they're like we're not coming and I go
what do you mean like our the delivery
guy says they don't have that I'm like
but we're both holding the same
confirmation yeah so it's like now my
apartment is completely trashed I gotta
go to Australia in four days I
just wanted this I've spent all
this money so I was like I
wonder what would happen if I just we're
also never uh we're never homes right so
when people us on like we have a
very small window yes for two days and
my half my day is sitting at home with
all around while I'm waiting for
the containers what uh have you gotten a
response from them yet because you got a
big following here and you used to work
there so I got fired he got really so
there's some beef here yeah remember you
know what working for them was a
nightmare because they're like a
Paul I remember like walking in they sat
all the employees down and then they
show a projection of a picture of the
president of the company not a video a
picture that we had to stare at while
they played a tape of him saying I love
my employees like The Simpsons I was
just gonna say that Holy Homer that
does not look like a leader holy
can you do all the Simpsons uh I can do
a good amount I can do uh Mao I can do
mouse Tavern what's going on Moe whoa oh
Bernie
hey Mr Burns and I can do this
wow
my favorite is I can't do Homer very
well but I love when he was like damn
you God damn you that's a waffle part
left up there two weeks ago I know I
shouldn't eat that oh
um you don't really do Impressions on
stages I know sometimes I do Ralph uh
what does Rob saying
yeah
this is one of my favorites yeah but I
the thing is uh I I do do it like when
my special people kept being like I love
your impressions like Impressions I'm
like oh but I think because like I
naturally do voices like I do a Michelle
wolf impression on my special and people
were like we love your impression yeah
does she like it oh Michelle I the
second because what have we watched the
British Bake Off there was a woman with
no hand and so Michelle and I kept
texting each other like every week like
are they gonna bring up the hand or not
they never brought it up and so finally
one day was the final episode I'm
sitting here watching and I just
unprovoked I get a text from Michelle
wolf I open it up as a voice message
what happened to the hand
uh I have to know
by the way I love the British Bake Off
because it's like everyone's just chill
so you watch American cooking shows
everyone's so damaged I'm like
you're making bronzino calm the
down yeah this is what I say I was like
American shows I'm not just doing my old
bits but it's like an American shows
like like you're defined by what
horrible thing happened to you yeah if
you've had cancer you're just Cancer
girl you know and then but the British
Bake Off fan it's a girl worst superhero
ever yeah and it's like you have to
shoot they're making you pit them
against each other so it's like cancer
girl versus like Iraq veteran yeah and
I'm like I feel terrible having to
choose he wants chopped it's just a sad
off it's like my son died of leukemia
here's my here's my penne I got
defrauded by a band clone yeah I lost my
restaurant in 9 11. and now you have 15
minutes to make an apple pie go and your
only ingredients are duct tape and an
eel go you know they're just panicking I
just got back from Epstein's Island
here's my trap you know
yeah
yeah it's crazy it's a crazy show but
yeah you're right the Bake Off is just
fun it's like lesbians making bread and
then oh and they're so polite they're
like we're sorry Mark your bread isn't
good enough yeah there's an old lady I
just want to say
um oh no my favorites will be like um if
anyone's finished could you please help
me I I haven't finished yet right I'm
coming over yeah start helping each
other you're like the yeah there's
no beeping too like ah Nadia when Nadia
won I sobbed I could not breathe I was
crying so hard
you can't do it you can't do it that's
the guy he's the she's the judge those
icy Hollywood yes Hollywood I
feel like there's a lot of Housewives at
home like oh Paul Hollywood can rape my
quiche any day
I think he's just got awesome eyes hair
the salt and pepper he's a handsome is
that young Paul Hollywood look oh yeah
whoa it looks like Steven Baldwin well
he is Greek and that that he does look
very very yeah it is weird he does kind
of a Vibe of like if Guy Fieri was James
Bond oh that's a tweet you gotta get
that out look at that guy yeah don't do
it now no no no I got peace I
forgot about paves yeah yeah he's uh
he's a hunk but my point is if you watch
the american they up their their
turkey dinner they're like
beep beep you know but this show there's
no cursing at all and then there's a
garden outside and they're like their
b-roll is like of a baby lamb eating
grass it's just so not what you would
think man Paul I would was smoking hot
I'm telling you you ever see people and
like they're like why is he not anymore
because he's just a little heavier no
he's I mean he's old he's good looking
now but I'm just saying when you look at
someone when they're 21 you're like damn
sure but I do receive people like in
their 50s or 60s and they have a certain
attitude towards like women or
waitresses and stuff and it's like oh
you were I forget you're like they're a
creep but I'm like oh you were hot when
you were young oh yeah and you don't
know that you're not bad anymore right
it's like when Morgan Fairchild flips
out on you're like oh you used to have
everyone nice to you but now you're not
hot not Morgan Fairchild he was hot Mark
you are such a she was hot
that Mark knows more I know who she is
what are you talking about yeah oh my
God I thought she was just well she was
on TJ hooker
it was a weird poll but of course I know
who it is I needed someone who used to
be hot who now looks like you know a
televangelist no but I know you mean no
no Mateo's right though it is 700 Club
yeah that lady with the pink hair that's
her but dude look at that come on you're
right people who like I I'll be honest I
feel like New York City is kind of like
that oh New York City is like a hot
chick that isn't quite as hot but it's
still a it's like so
much of the city is like deal with it
yeah
like the noise is non-stop here the
everything's working the rent is
jacked up yeah you're right yeah
like hey what not everyone wants to
you anymore yeah we're going to
Nashville Nashville Austin
say I just can't get over them all the
people in March the role that Jacks he
throws Morgan fair I think it was a good
bull hey man it was too easy yeah it's
trying to be a little more original here
hey man she's having kind of a moment
too she's back she's back oh yeah she's
she's doing great he wrote a book the
documentary yeah but uh she's a
television look at me look at that Mark
You Are Holy that's not her no okay wait
who is that woman on the right though
because that woman
that was the last one
I didn't even I didn't even I had no
reaction anymore
she's uh not Landing you you are oh my
God yeah look you are nuts kidding holy
yeah I will not be getting hard
tonight yeah all right I used to see her
on infomercials all the time and as a
kid I was like why does she feel like
she looks so uncomfortable for example
someone who couldn't stop they just kept
going with the surgery and it's it's
ruined I heard that could happen if you
get too much hair too oh no
I don't think that like hair it's really
not that much more but you know let me
just say we're flying through this but I
had a thing you talked about
um Madeline Khan singing opera
you know who else sang Opera Jim
Jefferies really the comedian Jim
Jefferies
on his uh throat and had to quit well
you could get them oh my God can you
imagine yeah he's doing he's
doing this beautiful song and then he's
like yeah yo you can't yeah right so
listen up you
well I guess there's no footage of him
singing I love I love it makes song is
gonna be a really great song
I bet you he was like a he must have
been a tenor he's so funny yeah funny
guy all right sorry I shouldn't have
brought it up because I thought he got
hair plugs yeah he did and they look
pretty good yeah I think Joel McHale
great plug ear plugs Jimmy Kimmel
McFarland Jimmy Kimmel oh Jimmy are you
supposed are you supposed to do this are
you supposed to just out all these
people I mean what are we out there I
don't know I mean it's like it's obvious
when your hairline's been sliding up and
down exactly Suddenly It's solidified I
would not have noticed with you that you
needed it I disguised it so well I
actually in my year post-op my with my
doctor he showed me pictures of my
hairline before and I was actually
shocked how little of hair I had really
yeah that really was quite I was like
whoa like I couldn't believe it oh yeah
the photos will get you you know like uh
you pull up uh Seth MacFarlane or Elon
Musk it's wild yeah Seth MacFarlane got
hair transplants I Believe by the same
guy that I love oh I have no idea I have
no way to prove that I just assumed
because he's in New York give me an old
photo of old old mcfar
oh no I'm thinking of someone else never
mind not Seth macfarland I remember
seeing something weird going on with him
when I didn't have to roll to two yeah
it's going back all the time but you see
when it's that perfect line like that
that's always a giveaway right young
Travolta what do you think
stunning stunning the butt chin look at
musk though I mean come on that's
bananas
where is he he looks like a different
person holy yeah yeah he does he
looks more alien there he does even
though he's hadn't been a space yet what
was he doing in the first picture like
was he like in The Matrix like what is
going on in that he looks like he's a
Chipmunks yeah let's not saying we can't
take back Sam I don't think he looks
adorable well adorable like a child not
handsome I love to take him back then
nice thing hey let's not say things
again we complimented that guy
I'm never gonna get over Morgan
Fairchild oh she's gonna laugh
she was on friends she was on like a lot
of yeah she was on friends oh yeah
she had a ride
I think Chandler's hot mom that is the
thing is like you know I do you do feel
for people who get rewarded only for
their looks and then you age and then
like I don't feel for them they were
blessed with beautiful looks yeah I
guess you're right and develop a
personality to go alongside that and
you'll have longevity I agree I agree
like really Sofia Vergara is doing it
right like she's stunning and everyone
wants to hire her she's great guest on
TV she's funny she's smart like she's
doing it right very attractive did he
have his hair done yeah I believe he did
really I think he just did it now oh I'm
thinking of uh no Jimmy Kimmel had his
hair done I don't know if Fallon oh
Brian Frasier I don't think that one has
really I don't know he doesn't you think
family would come up come on here I
think he's busy he's busy but I feel
like he'd be busy but what is he doing
yeah right now let's try to get Fallon
on here I would love that film and
Fortune feature just had him on her
podcast let's slide into his DMS he
would be a great drinking guest no
good stories we have to cancel the shows
I sat behind him I know I sat behind him
in a Rangers game once and he was so
cool great guy he seems nice
yeah he's like Matt Damon I had dinner
with Matt Damon once whoa what he came
to see Tom Papa's show and they loved me
when I walked in they were like come sit
with us and I was so uncomfortable we
had dinner he was a little tipsy but
like having a good time like yeah his
wife and then they came downstairs to
watch me McDougall and they wanted like
pic and I was like what is going is
there a picture yeah there's still a
picture of all the table together I love
it and my dumb hat on and Tom pop was
there and that's great that's one of the
fun things about the seller
will show up but if it does I'd be blown
away you gotta get that puppy on
Instagram
I have the picture somewhere I can find
it Matt Damon would you yeah all right
see he goes uh night and day for me
sometimes like man that's a good looking
guy well like definitely younger man oh
he's like an actor man he does like he
shifts his body that's true it's like I
don't want to Christian Bale in The
Machinist but oh yeah it looks pretty
good in American Psycho it seems really
stressful and I can't tell if he's
gorgeous or odd look like he's pretty
handsome really I mean bail he's not
handsome no he is but I look at the
straight guys are fighting for him what
the hell
pull him up in American Psycho he's
ridiculous he's handsome no lips really
no I don't have big lips either but I
have more lips than that
I thought he was like the prototype for
a hunk yeah he's ripped in that movie
um but that's exciting we're both doing
Chicago back that's gonna be great Go
Cubs Go White Sox sorry not the Cubs all
right Wrigley Field is just I love
Ridley fish oh I've never been I love
hep C I gotta go there
you have to go there it's historically
where a construction hat it might fall
on you damn Throwing Shade it's funny as
I grew up my family's all South Side
White Sox Chicago fans and so like I
just I don't even like sports I could
give a about the Cubs or the White
Sox but I just hear the Cubs I'm like oh
because I've been to those Cubs games
and oh just trash shots and I'm not like
Kaminsky was any better or whatever it's
U.S cellular or I don't know a cricket
now but um it's uh they it just it's too
it's very Yuppie oh got it got it okay
and it's right next to Boys Town I think
they call it North Halsted now but the
gay area of Chicago and so when the
games would get out it was like a flood
of straight dudes coming out of the gay
streets and we're like duh go away there
wasn't a little bit like he's all right
none of it but you know what's funny for
Halloween once my friends and I went
dressed as the First Wives Club uh yeah
and when we were walking through
Wrigleyville uh all the straight guys
like are you guys Hillary Clinton or
something the second we literally like
we walk one street over we go into Boys
Town and they're like
[Music]
Leon was hot in her day stunning
stunning that's a funny movie it doesn't
look bad now it's a good movie in the
ending and we we did like the whole
white dress and we did the dance and
everything and yeah what's the deal with
bet to me bet is just a
like a poor man's Babs no bet is
completely different than Streisand oh
okay Streisand's very like
and now I'm going to sing a song and
you're going to enjoy it and then I'm
gonna direct and I in this all I want to
live in Malibu and look at my flowers
yeah you know uh Bette Midler is like an
actress she's a dancer she's an
Entertainer Barbara's an actress she's
funny girl she's in that bogdanovich
movie too and she's in a lot more active
than Barbara Barbara's a great actress
but she could she's done a lot okay a
lot more I mean singer at Barbara's
Beyond yeah all right but Bette Midler
is an Entertainer and uh she got started
what's a good what's a good comp for
Bette Midler what do you mean like
someone else similar oh someone
comparable I mean she's a little like
and what's her big hit did she have a
big hit oh my God you ever know
of course that's a classic you should
know that from Seinfeld I know you are
she was breaking talented yeah she was
great in Seinfeld but um yeah I would
say Barbara's more of a singer director
that's more of an Entertainer got it got
it okay okay
Barbara would tell you she's like I was
I wanted to be an actress when I was
younger what's the movie She's in with
Lion O'Neill the bug Donovan pull that
you know what I'm talking about Barbra
Streisand maybe Bernadette Peters yeah
oh no what's up doc what's up doc yeah
yeah yeah
Barbara was and Barbara at what's up
talk was hot she had the long straight
ah it's so hot she was she was very good
looking her husband's nothing to sneeze
at either Brolin no he Brolin's hot yeah
okay we're getting she looks kind of
like Jennifer Aniston oh yeah
I love you so much hey I'd her to look
more Jewish like Jewish AI on Aniston my
favorite thing that Streisand said is
she did this concert in Central Park in
like 1969. it was 200 000 people showed
up wow she walks out and everyone's
screaming she's so New York she goes I
haven't done nothing yet no is she
Brooklyn Brooklyn oh my God I love it
absolutely Brooklyn Brooklyn
what broke Streisand what was like the
thing the Barbra Streisand I'm glad you
asked me this question so Barbra
Streisand she was dirt poor dad died
when she was 14 months old she had to
live in a a one bedroom with her
grandparents her brother her mother she
slept on a cot and uh when she graduated
high school she wanted to become an
actress and a singer so she brought this
cot with her she carried around she
slept in six different apartments one of
them was a piano Studio every night wow
an apartment all these keys and she
would say in different places every
night and she's saying in the village at
a place called The bonsoir where she
opened for Phyllis Diller
Stiller was the one to be like everyone
should watch her and uh
oh yeah oh yeah they were tied to the
end I didn't know Phyllis Dillard's act
at all I don't either I feel bad about
hysterical I'm ugly I'm
unfuckable
you should you should look at old
Phyllis Diller I've seen her on panel
and it's great yeah on piano she's
I've seen that I mean you in
particular it's it's joke after joke
after joke she does the things I like
jokes no I you know what I mean but it's
like she she does the whole thing where
she roasts um uh Phil Stiller
mother-in-law type in mother-in-law and
it's just it is just 20 minutes and how
she memorized it I have no idea no not
that one uh
scroll down a little bit oh Lucille Ball
that's fine fat jokes try that one fat
jokes here we go this is a tough set if
the mother-in-law ever comes to the show
that's true that's great and you gotta
have a million of those just like that
was in a minute and a half I know she's
and the whole thing is that so yeah how
many jokes did she write then memorize
love it do you need me to go through
that's like damn her and Joan butthead I
know loved each other oh I love that not
only that Phyllis sat in the front row
of all of Jones shows when she started
and laughed louder than anybody and they
stayed friends till the end to the very
end Joan was one of the last people to
have like a lunch with her right did you
know John no I was like I literally was
a new face it was like 12 years ago or
something and she died and it was I was
devastated because she's my number one
yeah number one so the doc on
her was so good so so good so great and
it's funny to like people like lizzo's
fat shaming you just want to show him
this and be like can we all lighten up
it's all right it's a joke
yeah yeah I think like we're not like
haha fat people are like that was clever
it's clever yeah it's smart do you think
that audiences I've noticed over the
past year and a half that like audiences
are laughing at
not controversial things but things they
would not have laughed at three years
ago definitely like don't say this don't
say that don't do this and now it's like
audiences are kind of craving definitely
do not feel like they have to be on
their best behavior yeah I don't know
what flipped it but something has
shifted for sure I don't know what it
was though I try to pinpoint when it
happened but I noticed is out a
lot more you hearing that so we could
bleep it but no I think we're here as a
seller all the time oh I wouldn't heard
that a year ago I think Mark's right I
think there's less gasping yeah it was a
period of gasps and you're like guys
come on I mean look it's occasionally
you hear it we're also spoiled because
we're on the road right we have our
people come out here and they'll be I'll
be at the cellar occasionally and I'll
be shocked at something like I'm like is
this really not hitting every once in a
while I'm like oh I know and then you
take it for your crowd and it works
it sucks sometimes it's like 99 of the
jokes I do on the road works for any
audience right that's why we do the
seller all the time but there's certain
things I know gay audiences will get and
so for like six months I was doing like
five spots a night at the cellar to work
out this new hour I was just going crazy
just like trying to figure it out figure
out and there were these jokes these
one-liners I'm like no one's laughing at
and I'm like I know this is funny and so
I tested out my new hour to theater in
May at in Tampa and all those jokes got
the laughs got the big laughs that no
one laughed at the cellar was that
offensive no no it's like the gays oh
and I was like oh my God and I literally
stopped on to go can I just say I knew I
was right because there was been I've
been doing these jokes for months since
straight people have just stared at me
like I'm a ass right right but I
was so I felt great my people yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but you have to make sure
everything works yeah in front of every
audience of course otherwise it's you
exactly no if it's like I do a Jew joke
it better work in Memphis right
you know it's like do you do a New York
City joke it better work in Houston
right yeah better work everywhere yeah
change the subway to the bus whatever
you whatever you got to do yeah
otherwise those Rogue those Road dates
get depressing because you're
like why am I not connecting I know
there's a button where you're not
connecting in your town like you're in
New York and the joke isn't working
you're like come on I live here but
sometimes people come they're all
foreigners that's true so they're all
like they're stories yeah it's like
because I say I have a couple jokes
about New York I said who's a New Yorker
here and like two people clap isn't that
weird and I'm like
where are the New York weekdays are
better than weekends oh Thursday nights
and Sunday nights are my favorite nights
to perform weekend favorite
awful and they're awful to go out
they're off to go to dinner I I would
give me a Monday or a Tuesday no Mondays
no no I mean to go out to get dinner oh
yeah I wanna I like I remember Sean
Patton used to have that great joke
about like weekends or for
rookies oh yeah the drunks he's like get
drunk on a Wednesday and I'm
like yes that's I related to that
so because it's just chill yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I prefer if I'm
performing in the city Sunday night's my
favorite I feel like at the best work
done on a Sunday yes because those
people they had a weekend probably and
they still came out they're like they
want to be there yeah as opposed to
Saturday they're like we got to do
something it's Saturday right there's a
pressure I hate any gig with pressure
and look it's not like to the extent of
like a a New Year's or like a you know
Christmas Eve or we need to be to get
but like going out on a weekend there is
an expectation and it may not be
the right reason you know yeah speaking
of Joan have you got I don't know if we
covered this last time you were here but
have you seen the red carpet uh what do
you call it uh what she would do the
same people yeah it's incredible I do it
did I didn't I show you what she said
about Anna Nicole Smith last time or no
yeah I think we did this last time I
can't remember like the doctor said no
drugs in her body just a lot of sperm
and she's still held on to her contract
with trim spot she's lost an additional
80 pounds that's good for you man I'm
like I can't imagine saying that I
cannot imagine I bet she was I bet she
was a good hang too yeah I bet
she was the best Lynn Compass we got to
get her on here to talk they were
buddies stories I think Whitney opened
for a few times really yeah yeah Lynn's
got a bunch of stories really good
stories too about Joan yeah she'd be a
great guest on here I love Lynn she
looks great she looks great yeah I saw
her on the Vegas TV you know they have
the TV piping out Vegas seller and uh
yeah she was on there she looked amazing
um I have to dip in like 10 minutes oh
why don't you uh before we get out of
here why don't you plug some dates
um I'm just trying again next week then
man yeah let's do that right yeah great
eye drops oh lumify the best they make I
mean like white your eyes will just be
white for hours okay lumify okay that's
old so I have to change that
oh look how young great there we go oh
we got some tickets moving folks
Australia's cooking I think the
Melbourne's sold out now and both cities
wait till you see this theater I hear
it's amazing it's so it's actually just
sold out I just saw the Kennedy Center
in February wow I'm very excited about
moving Denver I can't wait
that's okay you know what come see me
the second show added September 29th 9
30. it's like almost
Chicago's still out why is it I need to
update my what about uh did I
see the Radio City or my nuts no but I'm
doing Carnegie Hall oh great room built
before uh speakers so the Acoustics are
incredible really yeah
legendary I have a song surprise at the
end uh Liza
um yes
I have a musical guest I'm doing uh MSG
theater November 4th and I have a I have
a special musical oh really R Kelly
hilarious
so you're in luck yeah come see me on
tour ladies and gents it'll be lots of
fun yes was it Mateo Lane comedy.com all
right where you at uh uh when does
this come out again
okay
okay so we got oh uh Bethlehem
Pennsylvania that's a big venue guys
York PA Toronto another big ass venue
Chicago Theater September 30th uh
Toronto is September 21st we're in
Toronto are you going
yeah I'm looking forward to that uh
Phoenix Arizona
57th yeah I love it Pittsburgh Cleveland
Columbus Cincinnati Indy and then the I
like the Egyptian Room uh I've never
been it's good I haven't either it's a
great room I think it's still available
I had a great show there okay MSG That's
so exciting Sam it's a biggie we got uh
yeah then Australia like you guys I'm
following your footsteps and then we we
just added
Vegas because of you I'm doing the win I
did the Mirage last time to mix it up
it's great and then we got uh Tampa and
really it's Fort Myers but it's
Naples we're back baby we're
back revenge tour cue the music
samorel.com your guys your schedule
makes me feel like I'm not working oh
well thank you Portugal yeah exciting
going like two weeks oh my God good for
you wait a minute
can we zoom out so I can see it's all
September oh because I'm going this I'm
going in October I was like oh yeah we
link up I'm gonna be in this in London
doing shows the exact same time Schultz
is oh no it'll be fun to hang but wait
we don't have okay oh yeah good boy at
all good play be all over Europe
Netherlands uh Denmark hell Belgium
Germany Ireland Glasgow London we're in
London uh the Manchester Academy
Birmingham and uh yeah I don't know much
about the UK then we're back back in
Hershey with those tickets are not
moving Michelle wolf uh country right
there oh that's right
uh
Tyson's that's basically DC Oklahoma
City Dallas oh I got a hotel you got to
stay out there remind me oh please Rhode
Island Denver Cleveland Denver two at
the Paramount nice yeah I love it Grand
Junction whatever that is Hartford
conquer mobile and New Orleans Santa
Rosa Sacramento Omaha Market comedy.com
get some Bodega cats Bodega cat whiskey
folks Bodega catwhiskey.com send us
packages to Gotham go see Mateo check
out our specials watch out watch out
Mateo's new special
it's on YouTube and and uh and also
another special check out all this stuff
we love Mateo and killer act go see him
and don't talk because he'll he'll tell
you what the what crazy that I do that
no I think that's standard we love you
guys oh sorry oh so I'm still potting
you know the guy who uh when they go
you're a comic you should be able to
handle it we can't handle it right now
tell you to shut the up
I hate that guy all right sorry I
slipped that one oh no it was great it
was great uh well we love you guys
Pavarotti Matt Peters we love you haters
you know thank you guys keep listening
guys do you have a bag or anything like
okay all right we got you a bag there
I'm a Chicago accent big
Sunday's the day
[Music]
could Samuel is feeling dangerous
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true